it is an absolute delight ladies and
gentlemen to see you all here tonight
I'm glad you're here you're in for a
real treat
you've heard we're marking the 15th
birthday of intelligence squared and
we're celebrating the spoken word we
look at the history of speeches and
speech making and the importance of
words I'll let that one sink in today as
if I even needed to now more than ever
before I think we see the ramifications
that a few lines can have as they spread
around the world for good or for bad
tonight it is a real privilege to bring
you some of the very finest read by the
very finest so I'm going to take you
through our extraordinary cast list we
have two highly distinguished speech
writers experts in the art form both
sides of the Atlantic Phil Collins will
be very familiar to many of you chief
speechwriter to Tony Blair now a
columnist in The Times where he
pioneered that analysis of major
political speeches and his new book is
called when they go low a reference to
that line you'll remember from Michelle
Obama joined the campaign speeches that
shape the world and why we need them
that's going to be a fundamental
question we asked tonight Cody Keenan a
warm welcome to you just flown over
especially Cody was President Obama's
speech writer during his eight years in
the White House he helped craft amongst
others the State of the Union address
the Selmer 50th anniversary speech which
we'll be hearing a little of tonight and
the farewell address in Chicago he's
currently working with Barack Obama on
his memoirs Phil and Cody then will be
discussing some of the great speeches
made by remarkable men and women they
have chosen the ones that they found the
most inspiring but to bring it all to
life we have four of Britain's
best-loved actors Jeremy Irons shot to
fame early in the 1980s when he starred
in the TV adaptation of
had revisited he's barely left our
screen or our stage since that moment he
won Best Actor Oscar for his performance
in reversal of fortune Carey Mulligan
won the BAFTA Best Actress Award for her
breakout role in an education she
starred alongside Meryl Streep more
recently in suffragette and took the
lead role in far from the madding crowd
Simon Russell Beale one of the most
acclaimed stage actors of his generation
hailed for his Lea his Macbeth
his Hamlet's I can go on you'll
currently see him in amando you new
cheese satire the death of Stalin and
he's the winner of two BAFTAs Jaden uka
star of the Donmar Warehouse as
Shakespeare trilogy Julius Caesar Henry
the fourth The Tempest an award-winning
actor who's also appeared in Mike
Leigh's film a running jump and in the
channel 4 comedy chewing gum a warm
welcome to all of you and thank you for
making this so special
but we're going to start right here with
you to Phil and Cody and to understand
what it is that pulls you into
speechwriting do you do wake up dreaming
of being a speech writer as a kid no
yeah I didn't even get into politics to
be a speech writer I got into politics
because it's at its most pure its of
battle ideas and I felt passionately
about a bunch of ideas and my first boss
was Ted Kennedy senator john f kennedy's
brother worked for him for few years
just as a policy aide i actually started
as an unpaid intern in the mailroom and
the Obama campaign came calling in 2007
they heard I could write and and I lied
and told them I could and this is my
first speech writing job so what does
that mean then when you say you can
write what had they seen of yours at
that stage was that phrases was it the
way you carried a message what what what
do you put into it that I'd written a
few speeches for senator Kennedy not
many because even have a dedicated
speechwriter but I always try to make
them talk about something bigger than
the actual moment the actual issue and I
think that caught on film well for me I
came right through the writing I'd
always wanted to be a writer and so the
first thing was was was Dickens and all
well and that they were the people I
wanted to write like and then I'd
realize that speech writing is the point
where writing and theater and politics
all meet and trying to find elevated
words for political argument became the
thing that I could do slightly better
than all my colleagues in politics could
do they could do many other things
rather than I could but I spent a
lifetime wasting my circle my life just
reading books that weren't on the
curriculum and suddenly that I discover
that turns out to be the best possible
apprenticeship to be a speech writer
don't do anything you meant to be doing
simply read all the wrong books and you
discover years later that music turns up
in your writing and we have brought in
actors tonight to deliver those speeches
do you think your job is to make
politicians into actors I mean when you
talk about that performance it is an art
isn't it it is an art and we use you
I've seen it done very badly and it's
very instructive when you've seen done
very badly I used to write for
a certain Deputy Prime Minister who I
shall only identify by calling him John
and this John and on a famous occasion
he was always rambling in his speeches
and I gave him a tip I said what you
need to do John is tell the audience how
many points you've got to make before
you start
he said I'll thank you that's very good
advice and he stood up before a very
large audience just around the corner he
said good morning everybody I have 49
points we've got little John Prescott
there do you have a I can't believe you
blow my cover just I'm just bringing to
the conversation in case um Cody was
there somebody that you found monstrous
- rightful no I've been extremely
fortunate that's actually true I you
know when you'd write for Ted Kennedy
though he would view it as more of a
barely even a map just something that
was there and he'd do whatever he wanted
to anyway
it was like force of nature I mean many
people will remember for example the Ed
Miliband speech which he learned off by
heart and missed out that middle bit
Denis you know the bit on immigration do
you ever have those moments are you are
you sort of tracing the you know the
lines as you go and you find that
somebody's decide to perform it do it
off by heart and before you know it it's
oh yeah yeah absolute line you stand
there the back with the script and
you're going through it hoping that they
hit all the right moments and don't
don't delete things but obviously when
you're talking about people the caliber
of Ted Kennedy and Tony Blair they're
perfectly capable of doing that and they
as part of the skill is to be able to go
off script and not make a mess and they
did it all the time and Blair was
constantly going off script and it was
he always landed it perfectly but it's
always a heart-rending moment because he
think Oh where's he going with this
you know you think please don't make the
news no don't say it don't say anything
interesting you find yourself a
and we think of a bomber in that same
way as being so lyrical and so flowing
did he stick to script or did he'd he
did and that's that's less a compliment
to me than it is to him in that he was
very active in his speech writing he was
very passionate about he was precise
with his edits and the words that he
chose so that by the time we went up to
give a speech it's exactly what he
wanted to say some more often than I
need to stick to it because he'd already
worked it through we're going to take
our cells int the first speech now this
is the Gettysburg Address Abraham
Lincoln something that I had always
thought was a sort of first attempt I
thought it was this wonderful
free-flowing thing but you've explained
Phil that there are sort of different
iterations of this before he actually
landed on the Gettysburg version oh
there are there's always been a myth
that it was just written on the back of
an envelope on the way to get this book
from Washington and like most political
speeches the Gettysburg Address was
written with quite a tight deadline so
you don't that you can't have long but
there are five versions which are extant
and there's a number there in the
Library of Congress as there's one
version there was a controversy recently
when Barack Obama recorded the
Gettysburg Address and he didn't say the
words under God which are the only
things that Lincoln extemporized in the
speech we're about to hear and the
religious rites were absolutely up in
arms that Barack Obama had deleted the
the phrase under God he hadn't of course
all he done was to read out one of the
original scripts with it that Lincoln
had prepared and he and he put it in
under the whilst he was there the rest
of it was delivered exactly as was
written and it is I think one of perhaps
the greatest of all speeches because
what it does is it captures in a single
phrase which you'll hear at the end of
the of the speech the maxim of popular
sovereignty down the ages you hear
Cicero in Lincoln because you get this
unbroken link from the American Republic
all the way back to the Roman Republic
for Cicero rhetoric was not just
speaking it was also politics the two
things were the same and that idea of
popular sovereignty is given absolutely
imperishable form by Lincoln there's one
last thing before context before we
which is that Lincoln was not meant to
deliver the Gettysburg Address that
honor went to a man called Edward
Everett who was around orator of the day
and Everett spoke for two and a half
hours an incredible flourish absolutely
dreadful we don't remember a word of it
it it's all there publishable if you
want to read it but it's terrible it's
really incredibly ornate and Lincoln's
plain style reinvents rhetoric on the
day and the time people thought this was
far too prosaic but it's become the
great standard of American rhetoric this
is Abraham Lincoln they could spread a
dress four score and seven years ago our
fathers brought forth on this continent
a new nation conceived in Liberty and
dedicated to the proposition that all
men are created equal now we are engaged
in a great Civil War testing whether
that nation or any nation so conceived
and so dedicated can long endure we are
met on a great battlefield of that war
we have come to dedicate a portion of
that field as a final resting place for
those who here gave their lives that
that nation might live it is altogether
fitting and proper that we should do
this but in a larger sense we cannot
dedicate we cannot consecrate we cannot
hallow this ground the brave men living
and dead who struggled here have
consecrated it far above our poor power
to add or detract
the world will little note nor long
remember what we say here but it can
never forget what they did here it is
for us living rather to be dedicated
here
to the unfinished work which they who
fought here have thus far so nobly
advanced it is rather for us to be here
dedicated to the great task remaining
before us that from these honored dead
we take increased devotion to that cause
for which they here gave the last full
measure of devotion that we here highly
resolve that these dead shall not have
died in vain that this nation under God
shall have a new birth of freedom and
the government of the people by the
people for the people shall not perish
from this earth
[Applause]
and it is that wonderful line isn't it
the world will little note nor long
remember what we say here and of course
that speech as Phil said probably one of
the most memorable in the world against
which we now set virtually every other
presidential speech no politician is
given as good as speech since no
politician has delivered a speech that's
272 words since and what's extraordinary
about it beyond its beyond its brevity
and simplicity is it does what any great
speech does which is it speaks to
something bigger than the moment they
were there to consecrate a battlefield
as a cemetery but instead he talked
about not just winning a war that was
still raging and still very much in
doubt but our very founding ideals the
very possibility about whether or not a
country founded on those ideals could
endure and of course Lincoln would not
have had a speechwriter well he had a
clock in those days I didn't use the
term speechwriter there's a good man
called John Nicolay who was his clerk
who helped him with the speech but he
did write it himself so they worked on
it together but you see in the speech to
the echoes of previous rhetoric so
there's Pericles as in this speech that
rhetoric really begins with Pericles in
431 BC in his commemoration of the war
dead of the Peloponnesian War and what
Pericles does is exactly what Lincoln
does there as he passes from the eulogy
to the war dead quite quickly and
transports it into a paean of praise to
the democracy to the city to the to the
Republic and and that that transition
marks all of rhetoric and it's the start
of rhetoric and democracy who at which
at wind because it's only in a democracy
that the words really matter because
it's only in a democracy where you're
trying to persuade where the acts of
persuasion is also the acts of politics
as Cicero says and that's what Lincoln's
doing there and so brief as you said
curry so brief it must have taken ages
to write you don't get that kind of
brevity without losing a lot along the
way no shorter speeches is much harder
to write anybody can write a long speech
short speech takes takes a longer time
it just went one point about the very
first words - four score years and seven
now that sounds just like the date in a
cadence but it's much more than that if
you work back from 1863 four score years
and seven it takes you back to the
Declaration of Independence not to the
writing of the Constitution that's
absolutely critical because what Lincoln
is saying in this speech is that the
Civil War is a betrayal of the
independence the revolution has been
betrayed and what he's talking about
with ever without ever mentioning the
word is slavery he has himself proposed
the Emancipation Proclamation and this
speech is about slavery and he's saying
these dead will have died in vain and if
this Republic is allowed to continue
with the blood of slaves and that's what
he's saying but because his audience
will not receive that well he's saying
it in coded language so it's very
cleverly done it's poetic but it's
incredibly brutal at the same time once
you understand and Cody's right this has
become the absolute speech that no one
has ever surpassed but every American
president goes to Gettysburg and does
their own Gettysburg Address there's
only one president who didn't make it
there and that was Kennedy because in
1963 he was due to do the Centennial
speech and he had to ask eisenhower
lived on a farm and gets spoke to stand
him for him because Kennedy had to go
down to Dallas where he did some
important party political work and never
came back and then every president does
the same speech at Gettysburg which is a
sort of cover version of Lincoln and
then in the last election campaign
candidate Trump went to Gettysburg and
instead of 272 words of compressed
beauty he delivered 45 minutes of
egregious trade about the corruption of
the American Republic it was and is the
worst and most disgraceful speech I've
ever seen because to do that anywhere
would would be pretty bad but to go to
the place which is essentially a secular
right and deliver that speech was really
quite an astonishing abnegation of
everything that an American Republic
stands for rites of passage places that
have come to represent that I'm going to
let you take us on Cody to Brock Obama's
Selma speech on the anniversary you
won't say this but I can you
had a very major part in what he said
that I helped him yeah this I always say
but it's true Barack Obama was our chief
speechwriter everything flowed from him
and we were just there to help but for
Selma this was another speech about the
meaning of America just like Gettysburg
it was you know in March 7th 1965 I
guess or 60s a group of mostly black
Americans set out to march to protest
for their right to vote and before they
even crossed the bridge out of town
their nonviolent protest was met with
violent retribution and the image of
bloodied women bloodied men children
fire hoses attack dogs they actually
reached the entire world and they shook
the conscience of the nation and the
president and it was sanctioned wasn't
it that was there was silence sanctioned
by the mayor sanctioned by the governor
ran on the bridge which I think is to
this day still named after a Ku Klux
Klan drag another cool expand and the
idea that just 50 years later a black
president would come back to that site
was crazy enough as John Lewis actually
said when he introduced brocco bomb that
day you'd I would have called you crazy
but and we could have just done a nice
ceremonial speech commemorate it and God
now there but Brock and I wanted to do
something a little bit bigger with it he
wanted to talk about the meaning of
America because even 241 years in were
still engaged in a big battle over what
we are whether we're a static
nationalistic fearful country divided by
defined by one particular race or creed
or whether we're ever pressing dynamic
ever-changing and we view that as our
constant hallmark so he elevated Selma
the place into the pantheon of great
American places but he also elevated
those people into some of our most
iconic Americans what could be more
American than what happened in this
place
what could more profoundly vindicate the
idea of America than plain and humble
people unsung the downtrodden the
dreamers not of high station not born to
wealth or privilege not of one religious
tradition but many coming together to
shape their country's course what
greater expression of faith in the
American experiment than this what
greater form of patriotism is there
then the belief that America is not yet
finished that we are strong enough to be
self-critical that each successive
generation can look upon our
imperfections and decide that it is in
our power to remake this nation to more
closely align with our highest ideals
for we were born of change we broke the
old aristocracies declaring ourselves
entitled not by blood line but endowed
by our creator with certain inalienable
rights we secure our rights and
responsibilities to a system of
self-government of and By and For the
People
that's why we argue and fight with so
much passion and conviction because we
know our efforts matter we know America
is what we make of it we're the
immigrants who stowed away on ships to
reach these shores the huddled masses
yearning to breathe free Holocaust
survivors Soviet defectors The Lost Boys
of Sudan with the hopeful strivers who
crossed the Rio Grande because we want
our kids to know a better life that's
how we came to be and that's what the
young people here today and listening
all across the country must take away
from this day you are America
unconstrained by habits and convention
unencumbered while by what is because
you're ready to seize what ought to be
because Selma shows us that America is
not the project of any one person
because the single most powerful word in
our democracy is the word we we the
people we shall overcome yes we can that
word is owned by no one it belongs to
everyone oh what a glorious task we are
given to continually try to improve this
great nation of ours
[Applause]
all those echoes of speeches that we
know the Gettysburg
of course the Statue of Liberty but then
this phrase which he has come to be so
associated with yes we can Cody you can
hear when J was reading you know I could
I could hear his voice again there is a
sort of liturgical resonance isn't there
to how he speaks what he says and I
wonder whether the words come from that
or whether he sort of directs that what
tell us about yes we can both I mean and
what's interesting about this speech is
that he actually struck yes we can that
morning that was them that was the day
yeah and I had to fight with him on the
plane to try to put it back in and he
thought it was too self referential as a
direct reference to the campaign and I
had to remind him you know the very Lex
lot next lines were those words belong
to everybody and yes we can was was its
we knew that people there would cheer
about this and this was a speech
specifically to the future to young
Americans were engaged in this battle
and I said you have to give them that
rallying cry so how self-effacing
I mean how unusual really for a man of
power to not want to put too much of
himself in his yeah it's a pretty solid
contrast to what we see today
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm always struck with the American
rhetoric about how self-consciously it's
a tradition so you've got that you know
you've got Lincoln in there you heard
but you've also got we the people we
shall overcome yes we can it's a
tradition that they quote a cross-party
and we we it's much harder to do that in
Britain and we've struck me before when
I saw that Kerry had chosen that speech
two things about it one is that Obama's
writing and in your writing is really
quite plain and the poetic elevation
comes from compression it's like the
creation of diamonds and in the
Gettysburg Address 204 of those 272
words were a single syllable and the
Bombers writings very much like that
there's no flourish as such it comes
from the arrangement the setting and
it's beautifully done the other thing I
thought is that if I were to do the
speech which I'm most known for
it was the 2006 conference speech when
Cherie Blair had said something rude
about Gordon Brown and we had to make
light of it in a joke and I found this
old Les Dawson joke which was my wife's
run off with a guy next door and you
know what I'm really gonna miss him and
it just struck me that you're well known
for an absolutely beautiful speech about
injustice not known for a less dorsum
gag I think that tells you something
about the nature the two countries do
you think that I mean from what you're
saying if it's all down to one syllable
words these speeches have to be said out
loud they don't work as well on the page
some do some don't I mean demosthenes
wrote that all great speeches should
should read well too but I'm not sure
that's true I think there are some
speeches which we don't need to come to
life they need to be delivered well and
you know I I have myself read some of
these speeches and made a terrible mess
of them they don't they don't come alive
unless you've got the the rhythm I think
I mean Obama has got a magnificent
speaking voice hasn't he wouldn't
whenever we wrote we always wrote for
the year and my reader to read the
speech aloud before you've been giving
him a draft and then try to you know
it's like the first time you when you're
trying
learn a foreign language in a dream in
that foreign language the first time I
could hear his own voice was when I
realized I finally had were you there
with him when he did the Pinkney speech
when he sang Amazing Grace because I've
always wondered what how'd the speech
writing meeting went before that speech
when he says what I'm gonna do is about
50 minutes in I'm gonna sing did he tell
you no I can tell you we this this was a
eulogy after the shooting in Charleston
and we'd already done over a dozen of
these and we were trying to find that
figure out what to say this time you
know that that's different and it was
actually the families of the victims
forgave the killer in open court and he
said that's it I want to talk about
grace the concept of unearned Grace and
I did my best but the night before he
crossed out the final two pages rewrote
them longhand I think Pete Sue's got a
photo of it somewhere and he we'd worked
with the concept of grace he actually
wrote in the lyrics the night before and
then when we were he had to be back more
revisions that morning and we were on
the helicopter getting off at Andrews to
get onto Air Force One he turned and
said you know if it feels right I might
sing it and I just said oh okay but
people do ask if we wrote in you know
sing here and you can never do that you
have to feel it but if you've ever seen
the speech you can tell instantly that
you know he's in a black church of
course he's gonna sing there's there's
an organist playing there's a guy with a
guitar one of the preachers binders in
shades it's happening he always view
then he would sing it yeah I'd say 99.9%
yeah Jordan I'm going to take us on I
don't really want to leave Obama on that
thoughts it's so extraordinary but I'm
going to bring in Winston Churchill hmm
you've picked the finest hour speech
Phil which is the funniest now yeah yeah
I could have chosen any of the speeches
from 1940 there they are all remarkable
what gives them their real gravity is
the fact that the the peril is real that
the Luftwaffe have been in the sky this
speech we're about to hear is after the
Battle of Britain and it's genuinely um
when the country is on the threshold of
complete de Lappe disaster and collapse
and that gives rhetoric great power
because you can say things of wait at
that moment and Churchill is the perfect
example of this because he was renowned
throughout his career for lavishing
verbosity on issues that simply didn't
warrant it so you go back to 1899 and
Churchill is a by-election candidate in
although he's 24 years of age and he
turns up at church hall and there's
about six people that and he stands up
on the podium he says never before in
the history of Oldham of so many people
had so much to eat assaulted and then
nine years later is junior minister and
he's in Africa and he goes to the
opening of an irrigation scheme and he's
literally standing next to a hole in the
ground and he says never before in the
history of Africa have so much water
being held up by so little masonry and
it's it's all true I wasn't making it up
every I'm just making speeches out for
indolence yeah he did it all his life he
lavished his skill on things that simply
weren't up to it and then but then all
of a sudden all of a sudden this
absolutely extraordinary final chapter
to is this random career and he's Prime
Minister in the war and then he hits the
the heights with never before in the
field of human conflict has so much been
owned by so many to so few that's the
speech which follows this one this is
their finest hour where he's defining
the war effort he's giving a fairly
candid assessment of where Britain is in
the war and then at the end he lifts
everybody with this hope
what general vegam called the Battle of
France is over
I expect that the Battle of Britain is
about to begin
upon this battle depends the survival of
Christian civilization upon it depends
our own British life and the long
continuity of our institutions and our
Empire the whole fury and might of the
enemy must very soon be turned on us
Hitler knows that he will have to break
us in this island or lose the war if we
can stand up to him all Europe may be
free and the life of the world may move
forward into broad sunlit uplands but if
we fail then the whole world including
the United States including all that we
have known and cared for will sink into
the abyss of a new Dark Age made more
sinister and perhaps more protracted by
the lights of perverted science let us
therefore brace ourselves to our duties
and so bare ourselves that if the
British Empire and it's Commonwealth
lasts for a thousand years men will
still say this was their finest hour
[Applause]
Carolee I want it your thoughts on that
to us it sounds such a quintessentially
British speech it is of course a British
speech in in wartime does it feel that
that could not be made by an American
leader do you think it's a different
type of language a different type of
rhetoric or would you not go that far
yes and I think the moments different to
I mean I think the extinction of your
way of life tends to be clarifying and
we we've never really had that moment
you know we've protected by two oceans
and it's also the time I dad's just
watching Simon do that I pictured people
sitting around the radio listening and
it was also a time where everyone would
listen to a speech like that whether on
television or the radio today you just
don't get that you don't get those
moments they're so rare where tens of
millions of Americans would tune in and
a lot of them now just tuned in as a
chorus of critics on Twitter it's it's
just very very different age I one of
the reasons that we Churchill is so
revered as a speaker and Lloyd George
isn't is that Churchill had the radio
and Lloyd George didn't Lord George was
an absolutely excoriating speakers
brilliance and his war speeches were
absolutely fabulous in the First World
War but we don't have recordings of them
so he hasn't entered the collective
memory in the way Churchill has there's
also course the facts of the war that
the Second World War is a more obviously
an easily a symbol just war than the
great war but really is because we don't
have any recordings of Lloyd George
because Churchill did do that the radio
he delivered it first in the House of
Commons and then that evening he went to
the BBC to record it and he was on the
occasion of this one he was in a
terrible mood and he turned up at the
BBC and was moaning there was no whiskey
and so in order to annoy them he refused
to take his cigar out of his mouth so
the recording we've got he sounds drunk
he's not drunk he's just got a cigar in
his mouth so
we could have made you do it with a
cigar in your mouth for authenticity we
decided not to this girl was um was
quite apparel for Churchill's and I mean
he often just sort of caught fire as he
wrote didn't he he literally did there
was one occasion when he was so lost in
the composition of a speech that his
valet had to say sir you appear to be on
fire and he said well just put it out
man and is there is there a sense that
Churchill knew or any of these leaders
knew the the sort of success that they
had achieved by the time they first
delivered it or does that only come sort
of retrospectively I think in
Churchill's case and usually you can of
course judge your audience in the
auditorium or in the House of Commons as
it was in his case you know immediately
whether you're working there you don't
know whether you're wider audience has
received your words well at all and that
becomes more and more apparent as we
have you know mass media and of course
the primary audience for speeches we
roads were invisible to us we didn't
know in what circumstances they would
receive our words we didn't know how
many people would we didn't know how it
would be cut up the one of the things I
mean you try and get onto news night and
you think well you're going to be cut up
into a very small segment so that's why
you spend quite a lot of time trying to
work out your top-line your soundbite if
you think if I'm only gonna get six
seconds on the news then I want it to
the right six seconds
you know if Shakespeare was gonna get
six seconds you think well I really hope
they do that to be or not to be bit
because you know that's my best line and
I want that up there and that will be on
his press release which is of course why
why sometimes now with politicians they
will stick to a line however long the
interview because they're so scared
that's pre-recorded that the line
doesn't get that's right they're they're
fearful of people at you having your own
opinion
um Cody I wonder if if when you were
writing or as he wrote for a Barack
Obama you could have a sense of
correlation between a successful speech
and a jump in public opinion or in an
ease with which a policy was accepted
was there anything that tangible to work
on no and I think that's I mean I wish
that was the case but I think that's
also a consequence of the times I mean
we were so polarized there's just very
little that any one speech is gonna do
even to move a policy you think how many
times we had to write speeches on
climate change even wasting time trying
to convince people that it's real you
know it's it's it doesn't I think that
the internals time that probably would
have worked you say of all politicians
of the modern era Obama is the one who
really owes his ascent to his rhetorical
brilliance yes all the way back from his
first convention appearance when he
really bursts on the scene and and then
the the campaign in his fight against
Hillary Clinton
it's his capacity for language which
really demonstrates I think why speeches
still count he is the the absolute
typical politician who is as good as
they get and I regard him I can say this
whereas in the new count I think he's by
a distance the best in in my lifetime
when I was on the US campaign trail over
the last 18 months talking to a lot of
people about Hillary Clinton and
rhetoric and they said you know she's
got the toughest job in the world
because you know she's she's through no
fault around sandwiched between Barack
Obama's rhetorical brilliance and of
course the comparisons people made with
Bill Clinton and it was sort of almost
unachievable that rhetoric was not
particularly her forte many things were
but that wasn't was that sort of do you
think that was ever part of the of the
the failure of that campaign
yeah I think she embraced that notion I
mean she made light of it certainly but
that's the her skill set lie and lie lay
and policy work and and bringing people
together and doing the nitty-gritty and
that's what she was really great at Bill
Clinton's a good example of something
very important about rhetoric because
there's there's a very fine speaker and
a fine
mind but judged in retrospect not a
great deal to say and the reason for
that is not not is not
to denigrate him it's because the times
didn't produce that kind of moment he
didn't have an event which goes down in
the authorities and the history books in
the way that Ronald Reagan did a series
of cold war speeches which are
magnificent and still anthologized he
sees and peace and prosperity don't lend
themselves to historical stage his
inauguration speech is so forgettable
isn't it sort of the least the least
interesting one of any recent I think
for the reason yet he gives that you
know happiness rights white this month
Allen said it's very difficult to write
in an aging and vivid way about things
which are nice I think there wasn't
there was an opening there that would
have been interesting after the end of
the Cold War to redefine what the future
is gonna look like
I actually one of the most devastating
lines that George W Bush ever entered I
thought a great line in his convention
speech in 2000 when he was talking about
Bill Clinton was in the end to what end
yeah and remember watching that a TV
going down that is cult yeah I'm going
to bring in the first female speech I
mean there are a plethora of reasons why
there are so few women speeches in
history but we have one and before Cary
performs for us I should just say comb
elegance got to dash off at about 7:20
so I'm very conscious of of trying to
get as much with care before you go to
film but maybe fo you could just take us
briefly into this and then we'll look
yeah well this is Elizabeth the first
this is a speech about gender because
Elizabeth the first is speaking to the
troops that gathered at Tilbury the
Spanish Armada is is about to launch its
attack and Elizabeth is answering the
accusation that as a woman she cannot be
a viable commander of the Armed Forces
don't think she will heels just gonna
to that I am come amongst you as you see
at this time not for my recreation and
Dysport but being resolved in the midst
and heat of the battle to live and die
amongst you all to lay down for my God
and for my kingdom and my people my
honor and my blood even in the dust I
know I have the body but of a weak and
feeble woman but I have the heart and
stomach of a king and of a king of
England too and think foul scorn that
Parma or Spain or any Prince of Europe
should dare to invade the borders of my
realm to which rather than any dishonour
shall grow by me I myself will take up
arms I myself will be your general judge
and reward of every one of your virtues
in the field I know already for your
forward nurse you have deserved rewards
and crowns and we do assure you in the
word of a prince they shall be duly paid
you in the meantime I left Handel
general should be in my stead then whom
never Prince commanded a more noble or
worthy subject not doubting but by your
obedience to my general by your Concord
in the camp and your valour in the field
we shall shortly have a famous victory
over those enemies of my god of my
kingdom and of my people
[Applause]
and this is the queen as commander in
chief isn't it a woman who has to
reassure subjects that she's actually a
man you know that she can't behave like
a man that's right and she's refers to
her father in the speech because she
knows that if the battle goes awry it
will be attributed to her gender in a
way it wouldn't have been if the if it
was a king rather than a queen so she
she does what you should always do and
she confronts that head-on and she takes
on that fight and she was greeted with
the great ovation and you say she didn't
wear heels well it's friend Jesse I
can't tell you definitely she did wear
heels but there is a huge scholarly
dispute about what she was wearing at
the time because the conception we have
of Elizabeth now is this formidable
warrior is really ode to that speech and
all the all the depictions of her in
various soft suits of armor and I don't
want to labor the point but there was a
very strong moment during the last
campaign where Hillary Clinton had to
decide didn't she was she going to say
you know because a lot of criticism was
how can we have a woman you know I said
criticism a lot of her critics would say
how can we have a woman as
commander-in-chief this was something
that the other side used against her and
she had to decide whether to you know
sort of feminized herself didn't she
or whether to sort of take the Elizabeth
the first approach and say I'm stealing
yeah I know I look weak and feeble but I
have the heart and stomach of a king
yeah I mean there's a certain unfairness
to the the bars she had to jump over the
hoop she had to jump through I mean
nobody made Donald Trump prove whether
or not he was capable to be
commander-in-chief you know and I was so
she and she didn't really have to work
that hard it's at saying it either she
traveled to I think 180 countries when
she was Secretary of State she you know
lived in the White House for eight years
of the commander in chief she was knew
all the generals I mean she was
eminently qualified but to make her
still have to go through these hoops
saying I know I'm but a weak and feeble
woman his ridiculous was Elizabeth
completely transformed the way she was
seen with his speech I mean again it
shows how important it was we don't know
for certain
this speech was ever delivered actually
all we have is the testimony of a
clergyman 35 years later who wrote it up
so we can't be certain that it was
delivered exactly as it was but she did
she was known to be a real fan of good
writing an Elizabeth was a good writer
herself we know that so it accords with
what we do know about her literary
capacities but we're not certain that
those words were delivered quite like
that but we can compare it to the words
of Everly in Pankhurst the laws that men
have made which she embraces the fact
that women need laws for women it's not
about being male
it's about laws coming to meet with
absolutely I mean Emmeline Pankhurst in
the speech we're about to hear is she
arrives actually from prison because
she's been imprisoned by the authorities
she was on seven occasions and there's a
gathering in the Portman rooms in London
and they don't expect Emmeline Pankhurst
to turn up and she does she comes on
stage and she's greeted with this huge
ovation and she does a really
brilliantly forensic speech about why
it's important for women to be firstly
given the vote but secondly why because
there are laws that men have made which
are only for the interests of men and
this is a speech in which she makes that
case men politicians are in the habit of
talking to women as if there were no
laws that affect women the fact is they
say the home is the place for women
their interests are the rearing and
training of children these are the
things that interest women politics have
nothing to do with these things and
therefore politics do not concern women
yet the laws decide how women are to
live in marriage how their children are
to be trained and educated and what
their future of their children is to be
all of that is decided by Act of
Parliament let us take a few of these
laws and see what there is to say about
them from the woman's point of view
first of all let us take the marriage
rules they are made by men for women let
us consider whether they are equal
whether they are just whether they are
wise what security of maintenance has
the married woman
many a married woman having given up her
economic independence in order to marry
how is she compensated for that loss
what security does she get in that
marriage for which she gave up economic
independence take the case of a woman
who has been earning a good income she
is told that she ought to give up her
employment when she becomes the wife and
a mother what does she get in return all
that a married man is obliged to do by
law for his wife is to provide her
shelter of some kind food of some kind
and clothing of some kind it is left to
his good pleasure to decide what the
shelter shall be what the food shall be
what the clothing shall be it has left
to him to decide what money shall be
spent on the home and how it shall be
spent the wife has no voice legally in
deciding any of these things she has no
legal claim upon any definite portion of
his income if he is a good man
a conscientious man he does the right
thing if he is not if he chooses almost
to starve his wife she has no remedy
what he thinks sufficient is what she
has to be content with the more one
thinks about the importance of the vote
for women the more one realizes how
vital it is we're finding out new
reasons for the vote
we need new needs for the vote every day
in carrying on our agitation I hope
there may be a few men and women here
who will go away determined to at least
give this question more consideration
than they have in the past they will see
that we women who are doing so much to
get the vote want it because we realize
how much good we can do with it when
we've got it we do not want it in order
to boast of how much we have got we do
not want it because we want to imitate
men or be like men we want it because
without it we cannot do the work that is
necessary and right and proper that
every man and woman should be ready and
willing to undertake in the interest of
the community of which they form apart
Carrie thank you so much arias
Carrie is leaving us for Graham Norton
but I'm under stirred that you can you
can catch her tomorrow
just hearing that and the sort of
simplicity with which Carrie read that I
was sort of I was struck it's almost
like she's trying to explain something
incredibly simple to a child you know
there's no soaring rhetoric there's no
romance or like you said there is no
grandiose right there is no sort of
soaring flight is there there's just let
me put this in words of literally one
syllable that's right her husband
Richard Pangos was it was a lawyer and
that is essentially a lawyer's speech
it's very instrumental the argument she
makes - because she doesn't dwell for
long on the sheer injustice that women
should be denied the vote you could make
that case it's simply an irrelevant
category womanhood to deny anybody the
vote and she does glance at that
argument but then she moves on quite
quickly to say the reasons why the
consequences of us not having the votes
are themselves iniquitous
and she makes it in a very painstaking
way and it's very interesting and part
of the reason she does that I think is
that of course Pankhurst and the
suffragettes in contrast to the
suffragists Millicent Fawcett Socrates
were renowned for their violent methods
so at least in part this is a speech a
sauna has just arrived from prison whose
the authorities are watching her very
closely and she makes a deliberately
downbeat consciously rational argument
so the context is quite important in
that plainness of style so you've said
something critical there which is a
rational quality would be something that
presumably men would admire and also men
at the time of course would regard women
is not capable of that so not hysterical
I'm not shouting I'm not going to burst
into tears quite and and interestingly
this this line that she says we do not
want it because we want to imitate men
or be like men she's anticipating isn't
she there
yes she said that a lot in all her
speeches that sort of thing she's also
addressing women because at the time I
mean bear in mind this is a century ago
not all of the women were on her side by
any means so she's also saying to women
of a traditional cast of mind don't
worry I'm not excluding you she's doing
something we all have to do with
speeches which is try and bind an
audience which does not agree so she's
trying not to lose women of a
traditional kind as well as win over men
so it's a very delicate task she's
engaged on and that explains the very
careful way she trips through the
argument and the simplicity is what
makes it powerful I mean some of the
best speeches throughout history are
given by agitators and rabble rousers
but that's just what we call them and
really all they're doing is holding up a
mirror to society and what we see is
uncomfortable and the simplicity of her
just describing exactly how society
works was uncomfortable like some of the
some of the greatest speeches and in
civil rights women's rights labor rights
embrace that and in the line you put out
she's it's not even a plea for special
treatment it's just a plea for the equal
treatment that we like to promise but
don't always deliver on because you're
telling people things they don't know I
mean whether it's civil rights most
people would not have known you know the
situation that those fighting for
justice were in or sometimes they even
do know and don't do anything about it
and that's what makes it even more
uncomfortable we're going to go to
Shakespeare now Henry the fifth the
speech on Crispin's day krispies and
Crispin Crispian yes so sometimes it has
an a sometimes it doesn't filled you
have a few years to take we're really
actually looking at to battle speeches
now aren't we one Shakespeare and one
much more modern yeah the other ones Tim
Collins on the eve of the Iraq battle
I mean Shakespeare there's no speech
writers joke which I've used many times
which is when it was written anything
you say your words will be read long
after Milton and Shakespeare are
forgotten but no
until then and I'm often asked who's the
best speech writer in the history of
rhetoric and it's very hard to look past
Shakespeare you know I am no orator as
Brutus it's and then this whole whole
sections of the other plays are actually
about rhetoric not just deploying it
Coriolanus being the obvious example and
Julius Caesar just cited and
Shakespeare's magnificent capacity for
rhetorical language is seen to wonderful
effect in this passage we're gonna hear
in a moment from Henry the fifth and
then we're going to have straight after
that a modern version of eve of war
speaking Colonel Tim Collins speaking to
his troops before they go into battle in
the defining conflicts of the 21st
century the Barton battle in Iraq the
politics of which are much strolled over
but it's much more rare to just dwell
from her and think about those people go
into that battlefield and what is going
through their minds that's what Tim
Collins is trying to do but first let's
have Henry the fifth with Shakespeare he
which hath no stomach to this fight let
him depart his passport shall be made
and crowns for convoy put into his purse
we would not die in that man's company
that fears his fellowship to die with us
this day is called the feast of Crispian
he that outlives this day and comes safe
home will stand a tiptoe when this day
is named and rouse him at the name of
Crispian Hever shall live this day and
see old age will yearly on the vigil
feast his neighbours and say tomorrow
his son Christian then will he strip his
sleeve and show his scars and say these
wounds I had on Crispin's day old man
forgets
yet all shall be forgot but he'll
remember with advantages what feats he
did that day then shall our names
familiar in his mouth as household words
Harry the King Bedford and Exeter
Warwick and Talbot Salisbury and
Gloucester be in their flowing cups
freshly remember'd this story shall the
good man teach his son and Crispin
Crispian shall ne'er go by from this day
to the ending of the world but we in it
shall be remembered we few we happy few
we band of brothers
for he today that sheds his blood with
me shall be my brother be he ne'er so
vile this day shall gentle his condition
and gentlemen in England now Abed shall
think themselves accursed they were not
here and hold their manhoods cheap
whiles any speaks that fought with us
upon Saint Crispin's day
[Applause]
we go to liberate not to conquer we will
not fly our flags in their country we
are entering Iraq to free our people and
the only flag which will be flown in
that ancient land is their own show
respect for them wipe them out if that
is what they choose but if you are
ferocious in battle remember to be
magnanimous in victory Iraq is steeped
in history it is a site of the Garden of
Eden of the great flood and the
birthplace of Abraham tread lightly
there you will see things that no man
could pay to see and you will have a to
go a long way to find a more decent
generous and upright people than the
Iraqis you will be embarrassed by their
hospitality even though they have
nothing don't treat them as refugees for
their in their own country their
children will be poor but in years to
come they will know that the light of
liberation in their lives was brought by
you if there are casualties of war then
remember that when they woke up and got
dressed in the morning they did not plan
to die this day allow them dignity and
death bury them properly and mark their
graves there are some who are alive at
this moment who will not be alive
shortly those who do not wish to go on
that journey we will not send as for the
others I expect you to rock their world
if you harm the regiment or its history
by over-enthusiasm in killing or in
cowardice no it is your family
we'll suffer you will be shunned unless
your conduct is of the highest for your
deeds will follow you down through
history we will bring shame on neither
our uniform or our nation if we survive
the first strike we will survive the
attack as for ourselves
let's bring everyone home and leave Iraq
a better place for us having been there
our business now is north
I'd forgotten the astonishing power of
that I don't think I had heard it spoken
out loud I remember vividly when it was
made it was on the front page of our
newspapers and going back to what you
were saying about Churchill in the radio
that for me was a reminder that this was
a message not just to the Troops but
very much to an audience a domestic
audience wasn't it of of doubters of
there had been protest the Iraq war and
there were a lot of people who really
worried about our position that yeah and
how the outcome can mock the rhetoric in
due course because the other thing was
really powerful about it is the the fact
that we didn't tread lightly and that
none of those things came to pass and
it's and it's now sounds like a series
of pious hopes which we know will be
disappointed and that happens in
rhetoric all the time and his speeches
don't make things happen most of the
time the most conspicuous example was
right back at the beginning with Cicero
who his Sousa philippics against Mark
Antony he ended up his head cut off and
his hand cut off and nailed to the
rostrum for two exhibitors to passersby
and if you end up with after a series of
speeches with your head in your hands
cut off you have to conclude it could
have gone better
that's Cody's such a sort of sobering
thought I mean not not that one
obviously which is but this idea that
we've called this this session this this
performance night words that change the
world what if they don't yeah that was
gonna make the same point that you know
that the Churchill speech doesn't really
endure if Britain fell if we lost the
Battle of Britain and that's how history
is written you know that there are a lot
of great speeches out there that didn't
endure because it didn't work out the
right way so so your perspective then
will be this is not a speech that that
lasts because or do you or do you you
know I mean Tony Blair as you know well
thinks we will come full circle I don't
want to enter a sort of an Iraq war
debate but do you think that we will
come full circle and recognize that it
was the right battle to wage do you
think in you know this could be a speech
that if you like comes back into fashion
I think Cody's exactly right anything's
a very important point that the the
speeches which really last over a long
period of those which tell the story of
progress and a victory and all the great
speeches if you look at them
collectively they are speeches that are
made at a moment of great importance
where the some sort of injustice was
named and something else happened that
was better on the other side and those
are the ones that that last and to bring
this back to Shakespeare of course what
the Henry the fifth was the first bit of
fiction which i think is an important
thing to remember what Shakespeare
writing still for a politics outside the
theater though yes he was very very much
so
and he's also Shakespeare is very
interesting how politicians have
subsequently used Shakespeare because
one of the things which has gone missing
from rhetoric in reading the 20th
century sits since the Second World War
has been the ability to quote know
Shakespeare Churchill studied that
speech when he was doing his 1940
speeches because the odds that Henry is
describing there are five to one before
the battle aversion core he's
complaining about the absence of troops
and all the odds are stacked against him
this is exactly the position that
Churchill finds himself in so he studies
that speech and he echoes it and
throughout all of Churchill speeches
you've got echoes of Shakespeare he knew
long large tracts of Shakespeare by
heart now could you do that now very few
people do most contemporary political
rhetoric is fairly flat and free of
quotation there was an survival free of
the Bible I mean Martin Luther King
we're gonna hear in a moment it's full
of the Bible we heard an echo of Yeats
in the Tim Collins the the tread lightly
tread upon my dreams but it's rare I
used to try and get drop little bits of
Larkin to Tony Blair speeches you know
they they make a mess of you your mum
and dad that kind of thing but he always
spotted them he had an unerring ability
to to notice poetry and then take it out
was that because he felt it was what
sort of too liberal elite all or no is
that the flow he felt it didn't carry
the thing that changes rhetoric I think
in the 20th century is actually a rather
good reason I think it's that the 20th
century is have such progress that it's
harder to make great speeches so when
you're when you're arguing to the
propertied elite in the policy in Athens
everybody will be evenly educated when
you're arguing to a 60 million people
democracy or in your case far far more
than that you're having to be more
demotic you're having to have a plainer
vocabulary because your audience is
wider is less evenly educated and it
inevitably alters the way you speak okay
I'm gonna ask you to take us onto your
favorite speech of the night in some
ways isn't it there JFK at what's become
known as the moon speech why did you
pick this one I love this speech it's
it's not even john f kennedy's best
speech i put his inaugural address i'd
put his speech at American University
above it but it's it's my favorite you
know since we crawled out of caves we've
looked up at the moon and then this
young man came out on a late summer day
in 1962 and said it's time to go and you
know for five years just for context
there'd already been a beeping up in
space from the Russians because Sputnik
was up there and they'd sent a man up
there
so there was a little fear he had a
purpose to this to frighten America
enough into pursuing a space program so
that the moon wouldn't be red someday
and he was pushing Congress to you've
got a bunch of different audiences in
all these speeches and yet he did it in
the most hopeful optimistic way and just
the audacity that we're gonna build a
space program from nothing and put a man
on the moon in seven years is the type
of thing we don't get anymore in our
speeches and it's a blast
there is no strife no prejudice no
national conflict in outer space
as yet its hazards are hostile to us all
its conquest deserves the best of all
mankind and its opportunity for peaceful
cooperation may never come again but why
some say the moon why choose this as our
goal and they may well ask why climb the
highest mountain why 35 years ago fly
the Atlantic we choose to go to the moon
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they're easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we are willing to
accept one we are willing unwilling to
postpone and one which we intend to win
many years ago the Great British
explorer George Mallory who was to die
on Mount Everest was asked why did he
want to climb it he said because it's
there
well space is there and we're gonna
climb it and the moon and the planets
are there and New Hope's for knowledge
and peace are there and therefore as we
set sail we ask God's blessing on the
most hazardous and dangerous and
greatest adventure on which man has ever
embarked
[Applause]
and we did and he wasn't there to see it
as the ultimate tragedy isn't it yeah
there's not a shred of cynicism to the
speech I mean we've we've allowed
ourselves become so cynical because that
way we don't get disappointed if you
expect that politicians and society are
always going to let you down then you'll
never be let down when that happens if
you can allow yourself to be idealistic
the joy in being proven right is so much
greater and of course there's some
propaganda involved in the speech he
knew the Russians were listening that
was part of it but to convince us that
we could do something that preposterous
and you know people died on the way
there but we ultimately made it it's
something that's missing from our
politics on the grand stage how easy is
it Phil for UK politicians to sound
optimistic no I don't mean now I just
mean it's it's very much part of the
American character isn't it and it's not
part of that sort of slightly sardonic
yes
British approach I always felt that if
any of our politicians had said yes we
can there be a sort of are you sure
no we probably can't you know I've
written quite a lot for American chief
executives and I've always felt there's
a sort of spinal tap moment where I have
to turn it up to 11 because they're just
it but it is a sense of optimism and
possibility and of course that comes
with being America rather than Britain
you know it is you can risk the grand
style when you're writing for president
the United States I mean I am I've been
inundated by British politicians asking
me to turn them into Barack Obama and I
just what I always say to them I always
say to them let me count the ways in
which you're not Barack Obama because
the principle one is nothing to do with
them it's to do with the the context and
the fact that you know a black man as
president of the United States is a
remarkable story it's a remarkable thing
to have and then someone with his
capacity for language to and that's just
not true if what you're doing is the
just after lunch spot at the local
government Chronicle you know you've got
to be appropriate to your setting you've
got to be in Cicero's word decorous and
Kennedy talking about going to the moon
how grand can you get that's the most
optimistic thing in the world we're
gonna shoot to the moon it's remarkable
come on in a moment to the optimism of
Martin Luther King who perhaps even more
remarkable Cody I have a dream Oh sort
of doesn't need an introduction it was a
speech that changed the world
really yeah for sure I mean there there
are two speeches that American and
school kids are required to memorize and
perform and it's Gettysburg in this
what's remarkable about the passage
you're about to hear is dr. King didn't
even know the day before exactly what he
was going to say he spent the afternoon
arguing with his advisors about what the
thrust of the speech and then he finally
told him to go away and he was gonna go
confer with the almighty the the passage
you're about to hear the most famous
passage wasn't in the speech at all he'd
been you know Todd talking about it over
the course of the year he'd been
extemporaneously doing it and until a
gospel singer named Mahalia Jackson he
performed
des shouted tell him about the dream
during his speech he wasn't going to say
this part let us not wallow in the
valley of despair I say to you today my
friends and so even though we face the
difficulties of today and tomorrow I
still have a dream it is a dream deeply
rooted in the American dream I have a
dream that one day this nation will rise
up and live out the true meaning of its
Creed we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal
I have a dream that one day on the Red
Hills of Georgia the sons of former
slaves and the sons of former slave
owners will be able to sit down together
at the table of brotherhood I have a
dream that one day even the state of
Mississippi a state sweltering with the
heat of injustice sweltering with the
heat of oppression will be transformed
into an oasis of freedom and justice I
have a dream that my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character I have a dream today
I have a dream that one day down in
Alabama with its vicious racists with
its governor having his lips dripping
with the words of interposition and
nullification one day right there in
Alabama little black boys and black
girls will be able to join hands with
little white boys and white girls as
sisters and brothers I have a dream
today
I have a dream that one day every Valley
shall be exalted every Hill and mountain
shall be made low the rough places will
be made plain and the crooked places
will be made straight and the glory of
the Lord shall be revealed and all flesh
shall see it together this is our hope
and
this is the faith that I go back to the
south with
and Cody tell us how that was received i
you know i don't know actually i don't i
don't remember watching the crimea
you've got 200,000 people there but i
remember watching the crowd as to how i
was received i mean you can look at it
today in a couple different ways right
the white house was which only a few
blocks away was viewing it warily there
were weary allies the movement itself
was splintered and uncertain even some
of the speakers that day had different
views of it some some had a harsher take
some thought this was too optimistic and
naive and these are still the same
arguments were fighting through today i
mean it's not like we've become a
post-racial society in the united states
a lot of these words you can still use
so when he delivered that was it seen
that he was demanding the impossible I
mean was what he said did it did it
sound you know like the Emmeline
Pankhurst speech like a very natural
thing to ask for or did it sound
ridiculous it's more like the impossible
and he directly addressed that in the
speech talking about the fierce urgency
of now that it's not the time to weigh
that it's time to press forward now he
spends the first half of the speech the
the bit which he did right which is
called a canceled check which is just
prior to that section being very careful
to say to essentially detect the
audience please don't riot because
Kennedy was very fearful of the of the
march on Washington he felt he might put
back the cause of civil rights if there
was a terrible event there and King is
very careful to to be very calm and then
as Kody says Mahalia Jackson screams out
to him and he turns and in his memoir of
the time Kings speechwriter Clarence
Jones remarks that that he turns to his
colleagues as are Shetty's doing the
dream which is just about the biggest
misjudgment in the history of speech
isn't it because he goes that is it's
just extraordinarily but I mean how good
is that is fabulous they're always late
so they had heard the dream had he
performed the dream to a smaller crowd
endlessly he done it the one he that
Mahalia Jackson scene was in Detroit a
few months earlier and it was quite
common in those days to do a thing on
the on the circuit quite often so
Kennedy's ask not what your country can
do for you he'd said versions of that
many times and what King did was as a
preacher he was very accustomed to
having little bits of phrases and riffs
and he put them together it would be
different every time
and yet comprised of phrases which were
common to him he had a real stock of
biblical phrases but it's still amazing
that he's doing it up there on the stage
with no script no author cue off the top
of his head no matter how well you know
your material to do that with such
control and to land it in the way he did
there is really quite astonishing I'm
just gonna feel the temperature here in
terms of the number of questions that
we've got if there's lots we shall bring
them in early just give me a sense of
who there are some hands coming up yes
there are lots of hands all right I
think at this point then we will go to
questions you so that's a very straight
hand there's one up at the top why don't
we start with you madam Cody hi um
question for you please it's very easy
to forget that President Obama didn't
grow up in a home where they might have
even known who Mahalia Jackson was so
I'm wondering did he come to have this
extraordinary oratory style in the sort
of vein of black Baptists all of Martin
Luther King did he come to have that
naturally cuz presumably he wouldn't
have had exposure to that until what he
was the men in his 20s when he moved to
Chicago yeah that's true I mean he's you
know he was raised by a single mom white
woman from Kansas his white grandparents
spent his childhood why ain't Indonesia
and I don't think he became well-versed
in the black tradition until he joined
tradie Church in Chicago obviously a
church that gave him some troubles later
on but once he did he really did I mean
he can tell you everything there is to
know about the civil rights movement and
its actors and we would get drafts back
with full inserts from them so I think
you've got one thank you a great event
question for Kody again and in terms of
speech givers or orator is currently in
the u.s. political system
anybody coming through who impresses you
Ted Kennedy's grandnephew JH
my answer man well that was easy
yeah I'm sensing a trend I've been in
Europe now for six days and I've gotten
that question six times so I get the
sense people are looking for some new
leadership out of my country let's move
on to a few more I'm gonna take them in
batches of three you could elaborate as
we go along yes ma'am you've got one you
touched on cynicism for a speech to be
truly great as a person giving it need
to genuinely believe in what they're
saying or have you seen great speeches
be faked interesting fellow put that one
on your side but not yet yes sir I think
all of the speeches that have been
mentioned so far have been positive and
I wondered whether you'd be able to
touch on when speeches have changed the
world for the worse yeah and whether
communication and the oratory can
actually convince people to do things
that in their hearts or even in their
minds they probably wouldn't want to
really interesting thank you for that
let's have one down here yes you spoke
of language and you spoke of moods and
emotions how much does the body play in
in speech so so full delivery how does
that matter we want anecdotes on that
one for right let's just look at those
three for now Phil just look at the
cynicism first I think you have to
communicate a sense that you really
believe it an audience will understand
well they'll they'll pick it out if they
if they feel that there's something
inauthentic or something contrived about
the event a speech is by its nature a
contrived event because it's very rare
for you to stand and speak uninterrupted
for 20 minutes but you have to project a
sense of character and beliefs there are
many people who think that rhetoric
colleges go wrong when politicians cease
to write their own speeches you Mary
beard is always making this point to me
on radio programs
I always point out so that that gives me
far more power than I really warrant the
the speechwriter is just an aide to the
projection of a character but if the
principal appears not to believe what
they're saying then that will be that
will be injurious in the speech it will
never work so I think the short answer
is yes you do have to believe it and
just the second question that is
unfortunately sometimes very much the
detriment because an example the the
obvious example which is unavoidable in
the history of rhetoric and it's dark
shadow is Hitler there are others
Robespierre was a brilliant speaker who
gave a fantastic but appalling
justification of terror which he
redefined as justice there are many
instances in the history of rhetoric
where terrible words have been
brilliantly argued
yeah I think that both answers are right
I mean people have very we lived in a
time with people have very sophisticated
detectors with we can tell when
somebody's lying to us when somebody's
not authentic the most recent example I
can think about the top of my head it
was president Trump State of the Union
address no I'm not trying to make light
of it the every almost everything he
said up until the end sounded like him
you know you can vehemently disagree
with the content but at the end there
was an ending that sounded like it could
have been written for any president
who's ever lived something about holding
hands working together and the entire
graph said you knew he believed in none
of it he did that to an extent in the
acceptance speech you know two o'clock
in the morning where everyone for that
moment thought this was a very different
man to the one they'd seen on the
campaign what was your sense about that
nonsense I mean you really saw the the
pivot coming right is he pivoting to be
a real president and the answer is most
definitely no that pivot has never
happened to me yeah there's an
interesting thing because Trump was not
capable of doing that convinced me was
he and yet that is an absolute staple of
the inaugural speech all the way back to
1800 and one jefferson delivers the
inaugural after the most divisive
election campaign in american history in
which jefferson accuses john adams being
pro english john adams accusative and
fathering a
a child with his slaves it's horrible
and then Jefferson comes to do the
speech and he binds the country and he
does a version of no blue states or red
states and all American presidents do
that but there's something in the way
they conduct themselves in office which
means that's fine and I grew thee when
Trump comes to do that it suddenly think
no that's really not fine and he's very
interesting in that respect cuz he's
probably the first president United
States not to respect the office and as
the audience you feel that yeah if you
do want more contemporary examples of
speeches that could actually propel
people in a negative direction you look
at his I mean there are no more racist
and it's Lama folks in America than
there were two or ten years ago but the
Klan is now marching without hoods and
that's because they have permission from
the present United States it batters
speeches matter gosh uh that's quite a
thought isn't it I can see now why
you're a speechwriter let's talk about
body I mean I guess you know following
on from that Alec Baldwin would say yes
the body is quite instrumental in
conveying the character does it ever
this body matter yes it does it does I
mean go back to my egregious example of
Hitler where the the whole body was used
in the and in the rallying cry that he
did he utters much more homely and much
less dreadful example you just think
recently in Britain Teresa Mays
conference speech where she where her
body let her down
she was unable to get through the words
but she couldn't get through without
coughing and she exacerbates it but that
by looking down to his amazed just about
the only senior politician it doesn't
use autocue she doesn't like it so the
consequence when she's on the podium
she's like this and that puts all the
pressure on your throat so when she
started to struggle she was unable to
clear her throat most politicians will
stand like that because the otic use
running in front of you there and it
gives you a much better connection with
your audience so part of her problem was
that but her body was was crucial in
that in that she couldn't get through
the speech let's take a few more
questions
that's a very straight hand sir yes full
marks there
why knock with the backs how easy is it
to write a speech which you actually
don't believe in it and have you written
one of that sort mr. Collins great okay
come back to you on that one
while he's thinking he was my second mic
yes why do you think in terms of
political speeches how you say something
so much more important than the
information you're transmitting this
just explain that again the speech the
speech itself is more important than the
information you're transmitting how
would you say it how does how you say
the speech how do you say how you say it
yeah and yes today we're now encompassed
by social media and online type
discussion and where the President of
the United States no longer has to think
about speech writing and making a speech
it just can make a tweet in a few words
where do you think the future of speech
in moratorium or typed well I wondered
if we would get onto that yeah
should we go backwards yeah if you like
yeah do you want to pick up on that one
then so we have a tweeting president now
why would you bother with a speech when
you can do it in 140 or 280 I actually
think that I have a love/hate
relationship with Twitter I mostly hate
it because when I'm watching a speech
that have held the president craft I
have to watch live reaction to it and
they're often reacting people would
people would grade the State of the
Union address or any other speech before
was even halfway through or complain you
know he hasn't talked about X issue yet
and I'm just yelling at my computer
screen that's like three paragraphs away
but I had to answer your question I
think it's actually more important than
ever because the speech is just Barack
Obama has always viewed speech writing
as a way to organize his ideas and his
thoughts on the page and put them
forward and to lead a reasoned rational
debate to lead people to an issue to an
idea to a to a cause you can't do that
in 280 characters and certainly not when
you know your greatest impetus is
yourself it's supposed to be a speech is
about to be to people about all of us
and tweets just don't get that through
I very much agree with that it is very
important part of speech writing is that
what you're doing is organizing your
thoughts and it's the process you put
around it where you gather and you think
where are we now and what can we say oh
how do we move forward so the process
you go through is as important as the as
a delivered event I think it's quite
common that our speeches delivered ends
up being more important than the content
the best example is David Cameron who
became president of this country for
precisely that reason President
President sorry delighted that whatever
whatever he was I'm trying to forget it
in 2005 he went to the Conservative
Party conference and him and David Davis
had to do speeches in front of they
assembled there's almost as an audition
for him in the next leader and Davis
gave her a wooden speech and Cameron did
if you remember a virtually content free
speech but he did it
it seemed extemporary he did it from
memory and he walked around the stage
and it was the first time you've seen
that well actually anyone who'd seen
Gladstone Disraeli had seen it but it
was new in modern terms and the manner
of his speaking said to the audience I'm
a new kind of leader I can win for you
and that was a really potent message and
so I think it was an exact exactly
example and yeah we're going to end on
that last thought the gentleman stood up
at the beginning what happens if
somebody asks you to write a speech you
just don't believe in do you say no or
do you manage to muster a way through it
no I'd say no I mean you can but it
wouldn't be any fun and it probably
wouldn't be very inspired you don't if
you're a political appointee Lowe as we
were you don't end up writing those
sorts of speeches so civil servants do
it all the time it never really occurred
to me that I had to do that I've had one
speech where it was a small part of it a
significant part of it was something a
policy ID cards that I didn't believe in
it was probably the best passage of
sustained arguments I ever wrote because
I was so calm
of the contrary arguments that like a
barrister that I know you once were I
was able to avoid the obvious pitfalls
of the argument and I wrote very
cleverly and well on something I didn't
believe in but clearly as a speech
rights you have to have a certain
humility
you're not the Prime Minister you're not
the president you are there to serve
them and to give them what they want and
if the gap between what you're being
asked to do and what you think is so
large then you shouldn't be there in the
first place we came to end with a very
special speech Phil you're going to take
us into this I think it will have an
enormous resonance today even though it
was written at a very specific time it
was written at the turn of millennium in
1999 the Clintons invited a series of
speakers to the White House to deliver
the Millennium lectures and this is a
speech called the perils of indifference
by a man who won the Nobel Prize called
Elie Wiesel cam who once said the best
thing that's ever been said about
democracy
he said that democracy is valued mostly
not for what it allows but for what it
prevents and this is a speech about what
happens when that regulation goes
missing this is a speech by Elie Wiesel
who is was a young man as he says the
beginning of speech from the Carpathian
Mountains who wakes up one morning and
as he says the beginning not far from
Goethe's beloved Verma in a place of
eternal infamy called Buchenwald when he
first arrived there he was separated
from his mother and his sister by dr.
Josef Mengele with a wave of the
bandleaders battle as v Zell puts it and
with his father he walked one way and
his mother and sister what the other he
never saw them again his father didn't
quite make it through he died from
dysentery a few days before the Russians
first burst through and then the
American soldiers liberated the camp and
in the speech in the Xtravaganza here
he's describing what he thinks of as the
indifference that the world showed what
is indifference strange and a natural
state in which the lines blur between
light and darkness dusk and dawn crime
and punishment cruelty and compassion
good and evil what are its courses and
inescapable consequences is it a
philosophy is the philosophy of
indifference conceivable cannot possibly
view indifference as a virtue is it
necessary at times to practice it simply
to keep one sanity live normally enjoy a
fine meal in a glass of wine as the
world around us experiences harrowing
upheavals in a way to be indifferent to
suffering is what makes the human being
inhuman indifference after all is more
dangerous than anger and hatred anger
can at times be creative one writes a
great poem a great symphony one does
something special for the sake of
humanity because one is angry of the
injustice the one witnesses but
indifference is never creative even
hatred at times may elicit a response
you fight it you denounce it you disarm
it
indifference elicits no response
indifference is not a response
indifference is not a beginning it is an
end and therefore indifference is always
the friend of the enemy for it benefits
the aggressor never his victim whose
pain is magnified when he or she feels
forgot
the political prisoner in his cell the
hungry children the homeless refugees
not to respond to their plight
not to relieve their solitude by
offering them a spark of hope is to
exile them from human memory and in
denying their humanity we betray our own
indifference then is not only a sin it
is a punishment and this is one of the
most important lessons of this outgoing
centuries wide-ranging experiments in
good and evil just to say there is more
to come Phil is just going to give his
thoughts at this pause what he then goes
on to do is to describe the feelings of
indifference when the Americans failed
to intervene and when everybody failed
to intervene and he asks the assembled
people in the White House why it was the
world stood aside he then does go on
though to say that there were people who
came and in the end the American
soldiers came and he thanks them for the
rage that they showed when they came and
like many brilliant speeches this is a
symphony it ends at the point where it
began and it ends on a note of hope and
throughout the speech vis L is saying
that's the importance of naming people
giving people names and he was prisoner
a3 777 to them but his name was Elie
Wiesel does it mean we have learned from
the past does it mean that society has
changed has the human being become less
indifferent and more humans have we
really learned from our experiences are
we less insensitive to the plight of
victims of ethnic cleansing and other
forms of injustice 'as in places near
and
is today's justified intervention in
Kosovo led by you mr. president a
lasting warning that never again will
the deportation the terrorization of
children and their parents be allowed
anywhere in the world will it discourage
other dictators in other lands to do the
same and what about the children how we
see them on television we read about
them in the papers and we do so with a
broken heart their fate is always the
most tragic inevitably when adults wage
war children perish we see their faces
their eyes do we hear their pleas do we
feel their pain their agony every minute
one of them dies of disease violence
famine some of them so many of them
could be saved and so once again I think
of the young Jewish boy from the
Carpathian Mountains
he has accompanied the old man I have
become throughout these years of quest
and struggle and together we walk
towards the new millennium carried by
profound fear and extraordinary hope
[Applause]
on that note ladies and gentlemen we are
going to end with our extreme thanks to
Simon Russell Beale to Jaden Luca to
Jeremy Irons and Carey Mulligan in her
absence and to both to Cody Keenan to
Phil whose book is on sale in the fray
and he will sign it for you what a
tremendous evening thank you all very
much indeed
[Applause]